διες περιοχές συνεχίζουμε τω γοεφέτος εδούλεψψε πέρση έχουμε κα άλλα σημεί όμως να τους βοηθήσουμε
να καθαρίσουν και το πολλά σημαντικών στελεγχώνουμε το τημα θασό δασικώ κολέγειον αυξήσαμε των αριθμόν
των δασοπυρος βοιστών και πάμε μεγάλη λίστα θελά πο ψεστο χαλούμε είπε για αποέξετε μάχια
τα οποία θα δωθούν επίδε το πάμε πριν τοπκι θα είναι εδικαιοχι αυτά γεορικοί επαγγεληματες
χτυνοτρόφει έχουμε γκριτήρια βασικό έτσι μ ανάμεσα στα κριτήρια εναι να είναι και σε νεαρηλικία
και να είναι καταρτισμένος δηλαδή να έχει γνώσεις τούτι που έχουν γνώσης παυ είναι που
μια υλικίας πιοκάτω έχουν αυξημένοι μοριοδότης και ο λόγος που το κάννουμεντούτο είναι γιατί θέλουμε
τούτες ιμωνάδες να νεπαγγεληματικές το πρόβλημα που έχουμε μεδώ χαλούμε είναι οι οποχικότητα γι αυτόν
ταο ημειωμένει παραγωγ θέλουμε να φίτούτον οι τουλάχιστον να μειωθεί αρκετ για να γίνει τούτο
θέλουμε να έχουμε επαγγεληματίες χτυνοτρόφους όπως θέλουμεν και ο παγγελματίες γεοργούς φυσικά και να έχουν
τις γνώσεις ή να έχουν τη δυνατότητα να αξιωποιον ταν χριματοδοτικά εργαλία για να λαμβάνουν
της γνώσεις που πρέπει για να υξίσουν την παραγωγή καιλ αυτά τε μάχια είναι ίδη
στην ιστοσελίδα του τηματος γεωργίας μπορείο κάθε νδιαφερόμενος να τα δεί να έρθεισε επαφή θα
δει τα κριτήρια θα δει τις απλοποιημένες διαδιγασίες το τημα γαιοργείας είναι υπάρχουν τα τηλέφωνα
κεί των ατόμω μπορούν να κάνουν και κάτι δί ανσυναντήσεις για να τους δώσουν κατευθντήριες
γραμμές να κάνουν τηναίτησύτους και ο θα ακολουθηθεί είναι νομισμένι διαδικασίας σε τρεις μήνες όμως
με τις απλοποιημένες διαδικασίες που έκανε το τήμα χτημα τολογίου και εντούτων τω το σημαντικώ
και ξανα ευχαριστώ μπορούμε σε τρεις μήνες να πον μέσα κλείνοντας κάλψαμε όλα τα θέματα
τα καστάθεμα ταρα ρωτήσωι επόμε τη μέρα γιατή μαρίά παραγριε στην πολιτικι